the other big hollywood news is your
stand-up tour
in almost like it's a movie in itself is
now being turned into a sitcom yeah i
did i did the stand-up show in america
and some hbo
which is a tv network over there came up
and said you know what do you think
about doing it as a sitcom and
my stand-up show was about my failure to
to find a wife and general
pathetic life as a loser and uh and they
thought yeah we want this on tv
um and so that's what we're doing is
they're not gonna come a huge dilemma
though
when they say to you we want to turn
this into a you know six parts
you know like masters and masters of
series that if you find a wife in that
time you ruin your career
yeah he'll keep her in a bunker sort of
where he already does keem her
no it's it isn't yeah you're right well
i mean it's not a it's not a documentary
so i could theoretically be married and
still be acting the role
it's going to ruin your jam though much
if you do get married
thank you you're just wishing on me a
deep and miserable lonely life
just so the laughs
is one of the episodes gonna feature
that sort of hideous wedding experience
you have it is
it is we uh yeah i i mean i thought i'd
met this woman of my dreams at this
wedding i was at a wedding and you know
you get stuck sometimes on a table with
people that you that you don't know
there was a girl opposite and she was
dynamite and we hit it off but i was
stuck next to this couple
olly and lisa and they had this kid this
toddler in a high chair just sat there
like that
just bashing this big bread sticks and
stuff and um and the mother wouldn't
recommend if you just kept going what's
he like what's he like
and she was exhausting and she she would
just dominate the table with these
stories
you know those people just they're not
really stories it was it was all that
here's one for you um went to the
i went to the um i went up the um um
the um the uh no no no no no the um
the um supermarket i went to the
supermarket
did a big uh did a big um shot i did a
shot
and then i got back to the checkout and
i'd forgotten my purse and i had to go
home for it
honestly i was thinking if if if that
story was making its way out of my brain
towards my mouth
another part of my brain would have
stepped in and gone where the hell are
you going
this is a wedding i don't know where
this is this is just some [__]
and she's wearing on and then her
husband who's quite a posh bloke pipes
up and he goes um
i recognize you where do i recognize you
from and i was trying to impress this
girl so i said oh i did this tv show
called the office
and he went oh the office yeah i've seen
the office yeah
not my cup of tea i'll tell you where
you're going wrong with the office
he said not much story i'm thinking yeah
because you know about stories because
you're married to bloody charles dickens
but that's not the reason i blew it with
this girl i so this toddler is sat there
the whole time right
and we're having some soup and for no
reason this kid just took his shoe off
just lobbed it in the air for no reason
it came flying down it landed in my suit
just no one else is touched i'm covered
in it and the mother lisa just went
wassy like and i said
he's like a
[Applause]
you've probably seen this harper's
bazaar harbor's bizarre
posh magazine news agency yeah there is
a man at the back of it what would you
like
uh problems with our dude they're uh the
most powerful women it's their 2009 list
the most powerful women in british
theater
and look at this picture how fabulous do
you look there
that was one of the funniest 10-minute
photo shoots i've ever had in my life
that only took 10 minutes it felt like i
literally had 10 minutes to run into and
we was like
stand like standing like this that was
me the whole time the wind was blowing
the lights the everything and we had to
like go
so yes yes she's so beautiful isn't she
you've got you both are absolutely
gorgeous completely manufactured that
it's all posted it's not post-production
but with the iphoto no
you know photoshop that's what it is
because in the research you know so they
did the research the research that you
did before i came on
well that somebody did yes and uh
you know and it's got the it's got the
lists of kind of various things
and it's got you know most powerful
woman in theater
harper's bazaar and then further down
the list this this is like how your life
has changed
previously on out magazines list of
celebrities who people would like most
like to drink their bath water
yes my heart you were quite high up on
that list
i know i think i was number one no you
number one number one
yes so what is it that you put in your
bath that makes it so attractive
it's just me and all my oils oozing all
over the place
who the hell was number two
[Music]
oh come on that's delicious
i pay a lot of money for that and when
you do when you do um
a theater when you do do plays do you
get
the kind of the science fictiony people
coming yes
yes which is good i suppose because
they're exposed to a play they wouldn't
have seen
that's true yeah i mean
they're all like that
i don't believe the x-files existed i
think it's a massive conspiracy
to uh to keep nerds at their computers
no i don't really i don't i don't really
fall for any of the kind of conspiracy
stuff i don't believe in in any of that
all that moon landings never happened
kind of conspiracy you know 28
of americans don't think the moon
landings happened
in fact you don't think the moonlight
has happened i'm sorry if you could do
that in 1969
yeah like we can't do anything now which
i mean it's like
i'm still changing hoover bags in 2009
as soon as we can get to the moon we'll
find all these amazing devices
graham will be able to make a phone call
when you as a child you assumed
that things would be better now like we
live in the future
but yes are we always told that at any
point about 30 years from
from wherever you're talking you're
going to have jet packs yeah yeah and
there'll be a monorail
playing cards where are they tomorrow's
world where are we
i'm still sat here why why isn't graham
having to talk to me up there
yeah as i float about the place that's
an interesting question
traffic why do we even have legs still
why haven't we evolved
that's why i think maybe things like
that those conspiracy things might be
true
i don't know anyway look the reason why
i'm talking about hang on
because your toast is not good enough
people didn't go to the moon
toasters are getting worse
[Applause]
they are they used to be great when i
was a kid now too many settings
it's either burnt or raw
[Applause]
one of the great things about toast is
it can be eaten raw with no harmful
effects
it's not the same though
anywho rant over what we did is we uh
asked the audience
uh what sort of presence they got and uh
some people in fairness
they didn't get well they didn't get
great presents
i've got some of them here now where's
uh
fabian fabian devoe now this fabian oh
hello all right no
somebody gave you that is that true
you gave me this my ex your ex gave you
this yeah
now do you have a dog no
so how did he explain it uh well
he said that at the time in the shop he
said it was
a lovely ball and that could have
like my cereals in the morning
is this some weird sex game
you supposed to wear a collar at the
same time
so how did you react do you open a dog
bowl what do you do
you go oh i love dog place
how did you react were you positive did
you slap him in face i'll tell you
what do you see what do you see
do you see a dog i am not a thong
i am a man i am a man who dries his hair
from one side
[Applause]
it's beautiful it's beautiful
and now this this is really pissed but
this is
this is what you're talking about oh i
love it
mango and papaya
[Applause]
oh i've often haven't i joke haven't i
opened the phone
and yeah so often mango on its own so
isolated
i see mango i want union i have it
isn't that lovely now who got this oh
you there lovely lady
now who gave it to you first of all my
husband you
you're still together just
and why was it a particularly bad gift
i'm allergic to shower gel
did he know you were allergic yeah i
think you've been together 21 years
old do you swell up or something amusing
when you
children i go red and scratch
that's funny enough i'd give a shout out
game for a laugh
it's lovely but presumably better
presents now sir
not really no no uh travel naughts and
cross east last year and
sorry travel norton yet
you've given someone a pad and a pen and
you've gone
traveled
[Music]
that is lovely i stand correct yeah
would you like it
no you brought it out with you tonight i
love it
yes any kind of travel at all are we off
darling let me fetch my travel knots
these lights seem to be taking quite a
long time fancy a quick game of travel
quick we're on amber i win
oh very exciting look i don't know who
got this
but nick look i found you a cat
this was yours brilliant well i'll give
that to nick nick you hold on to that
so uh you've got it when the butt when
the motorbike arrives okay there you go
nick
okay handy trainers they'll come off
nice and quick okay
so you've got a cat now uh who else have
i got uh
right now very quickly we got an email
from someone uh
with this picture and i think it's let's
look at the picture this is this is the
gif this is kelly
oh no now is kelly kelly's here
there's kelly hello where's kelly i love
getting looking at her hands like
like you've never seen that picture
before in your life so your
husband your husband bought you
that outfit
thinking you'd like it i think kelly's
face says it all in the picture really
because it's as if so you went into a
shop and said i'd like something
suitable for my wife to be buried in
what what is it is it's a must be
pajamas yes
did you think they were gonna be sexy
not at all no
at least it does say angel on the tits
so it's like it's
it's sort of it's sort of nice going on
a winter holiday you know
it was cold i don't think anyone's that
cold
unless you're at six months old
so did you have to open it up pretend to
be pleased no i did not pretend to be
pleased
well listen sir you're obviously uh not
very good at
choosing good presence right so i
thought i'd give you some experience of
a good
present would you would you help me test
a good present sir sure what's your name
neil neil okay what it is somebody sent
me
uh this phone right and they make
extravagant claims about it so now is it
on no just check that it's on yes it is
on
so if you take this take this take this
phone okay
they claim right this phone
will uh operate uh under extreme
thermal condition so it's very cold
outside two degrees having just been
there very good
so if you follow the camera there i'll
ring you
as you're walking and then we'll see if
it's still working when you're outside
in the cold all right so uh now
have i got the number for that phone i
hope i do six six
seven two
okay it's calling
it's freezing it's ringing hello brian
oh hello neil
i'm here okay you keep keep walking to
you outside
now can you still can you still hear me
i can still hear you okay stop around
now um neil that's very good so
with it's a solemn xp3 enduro apparently
it's the world's toughest phone and it's
not just thermal conditions they they
say
um it it i mean they make other claims
for the phone it says here uh neil
that it's a water and liquid proof
uh yeah okay i guess
[Applause]
it's also just micro particle proof
can you hear me now i can't see anything
i can hear you
and uh lastly it is uh really resistant
to shock and impact neal
can you hear me now
kelly enjoyed it
you